well they'll be things that are great
accomplishments I think we will
recognize that he kept us safe these
last six years and that was not easy to
do he fought for the patriot act he made
sure that when al Qaeda was calling we
were listening he made sure that the
terrorists that were caught we
interrogated to find out what they knew
so we could protect our country he kept
us safe that's the first responsibility
of a president secondly he went after
the guys that went after us no more in
this world do you say hey we can go
after America and nothing happens he
made sure people realize their
consequences for for attacking us they
attacked us at the USS Cole they
attacked us and in Saudi Arabia they
attacked us in our in African embassies
in Tanzania and Kenya and and actually
they attacked our Marines in Lebanon we
didn't respond and then finally when
George Bush was president and they
attacked us on 9/11 we did respond in a
major and aggressive way and they know
that their consequences of attacking us
there his commitment to education and No
Child Left Behind I also support and his
effort to help people get prescription
drugs I think was a good effort although
I think we should have reformed Medicare
as part of the process because the
Medicare Part D alone I'm afraid added a
huge new entitlement that I think will
not be a positive part of his legacy
there are other elements that were not
as successful I wish we would have been
able to see the reform of entitlements
that just just didn't happen he tried
that was unsuccessful and of course the
conflict in Iraq was not superbly
managed following the collapse of Saddam
Hussein we we just did not have the
right level of troop strength we did not
have the rules of engagement or the the
plans and preparations in place to to
have Iraq become stable and the time
frame it should have become stable so
then we will be pluses and minuses but
overall we'll know that this is a
president who did what he thought was
right for America at every turn
you